[Music]  the world entered a new dog age I was  one of the last synthetics to survive  you sure this is the place yeah she's  here wake up I've been looking for you  for a long go meet death  because then and that patient my name  she's the perfect woman hey  incorruptible  [Music]  I think I want me a low buddy  [Music]  why are you saying me maybe I'm not  functioning never had this feeling  before it was at that moment I became  aware of exactly how different I was I  had to set things right  you took away the one thing that was my  two guns  ten bullets we're gonna need everyone  like that's the bad thing is so me  welcome to paradise  this isn't paradise  [Music]